in a normal environment you're always
going to have echo chambers and so
what's the opposite of an echo chamber i
i created a term for because i think we
need it which is called an ideal lab an
idea lab right it's like people treat
it's like people act like scientists
even if they're not doing science they
just treat their ideas like science
experiments and they toss them out there
and everyone disagrees and disagreement
is like the game everyone likes to
disagree you know on a certain text
thread where everyone is just you know
saying you know it's almost like someone
throws something out and just says an
impulse or the rest of the group to say
i think you're being like uh overly
general there or i think like aren't you
kind of being i think that's like your
bias showing and it's like no one's
getting offended because it's like we're
all just messing we all of course
respect each other obviously we're just
we're just
you know trashing each other's ideas and
that the whole group becomes smarter
you're always going to have idea labs
and echo chambers right in different
communities and most of us participate
in both of them you know and you know
maybe in your marriage is a great idea
lab you love to disagree with your your
spouse and maybe in but this group of
friends or your family at home you know
you know in front of that sister you do
not bring up politics because she's now
enforced when that happens her bullying
is forcing the whole room to be an echo
chamber to appease her now what's what
scares me is that usually you have these
things existing kind of in bubbles and
usually there's like and they each have
their natural defenses against each
other so an
echo chamber person stays in their echo
chamber they don't like they will cut
you out they don't they don't have to be
friends with people who disagree with
them you notice that they will cut you
out they'll cut out their parents if
they voted for trump or whatever right
so
the they're um
that's how they do it they will say i'm
gonna stay inside of an echo chamber
safely so my ideas which i identify with
um because my primitive mind is doing
the thinking it are not gonna ever have
to get challenged because it feels so
scary and awful for that to happen
but if they leave and they go into an
ideal lab environment they're going to
people are going to say what no they're
going to disagree and they're going to
say and the person's going to try to
bully you know they're going to say uh
that's really offensive and people say
no it's not and they're going to they're
going to immediately say these people
are [ __ ] right so the echo chamber
uh person uh it doesn't have much power
once they leave the echo chamber
likewise the idea lab person they have
this great environment but if they go
into an echo chamber where everyone else
is and they do that they'll get kicked
out of the group they'll get branded as
something you know a denier a racist uh
you know a right winger a radical you
know these these these nasty words um
the thing that i don't like right now is
that the echo chambers have
found ways to forcefully expand
into
places that normally
are have a pretty good immune system
against echo chambers like universities
like science journals places where
usually it's like there's a strong idea
lab culture they're veritas you know you
know that that's that's an idea lab
slogan um you have is that these people
have found a way
to
a lot of people have found a way to
actually go out of their thing and keep
their echo chamber by making sure that
everyone is scared because they can
punish anyone whether you're in their
community or not
that's uh all brilliantly put when's the
book coming up
any idea june
july we're not quite sure yet okay i
can't wait thanks it's awesome do you
have a title yet or you can't talk about
that still working out okay
you